[Music]
today's question comes from hannah in
illinois she says i've always struggled
with emotional spending to fill a void
in my life in stressful situations
my husband and i started dating he was
debt free which prompted me to want to
get out of debt i was able to pay off
four grand before we got married and
then my husband paid off the rest of my
five thousand dollars debt
we were debt-free for 10 months until
the pandemic hit and the stress spiraled
into spending on my credit cards i
thought i would be able to pay them off
but i kept spending and the shame of the
debt overwhelmed me so i kept it a
secret my husband was angry when he
finally had a discussion about my debt
and i closed my accounts how do i
how do i handle the shame of past
mistakes and avoid emotional spending i
want to do better in our finances and
work together but my husband doesn't
believe i am willing to change
man dave there's a lot here um first i
don't know that her husband's
angry about the spending as much as the
dishonesty and the deceit and the as we
call around here financial infidelity
here i'm sure he was upset about the
spinning but more of the violation of
trust
um
so the way i've heard guilt and shame
framed does guilt is
when you say i've done something
that violates my moral boundaries
shame is when you say i am
like not i cheated i should feel guilty
about cheating on a test
i'm a cheater i carry that shame around
with me and
so when anyone says how do i get rid of
my shame i think you pull your i say i'm
going to pull myself away from these set
of behaviors and i'm going to say i'm
going to stop doing these things
your husband uh
doesn't believe you're willing to change
because i don't see here that i'm that
you're willing to change
i see i hear dave in this language this
over and over
um
i'm just out of control with this thing
it controls me nothing i can do about it
and i don't have a choice in this stones
i stone cold disagree with that yeah i
if you label yourself which is shaming
you're right
if you i'm an emotional spender
then you're no longer uh uh held
accountable for the fact that you're
just not being an adult that's right
like i'm six two i have to bend over to
get into a
a four foot you know
fence let's say
that's a that's a fact i'm six foot two
she is not an emotional spender six foot
two right she has labeled herself an
emotional spin right and that's how she
has chosen to cope with things in the
past well and it lets you off the hook
for
for the pain of the responsibility to
change that's right if you label
yourself well i've got this disease
i've got a problem and i've got this
disease and so i'm stuck can't help it
i'm just the way i am so hannah you know
what you do you get rid of all of your
cards you get rid of all of your
internet access i mean how far do you
want to go to keep your marriage how far
do you want to go to stop this kind of
behavior
do you want to get to spend some time
with the counselor and get to the root
of what why you feel the need to do i
mean you could go to the ends of the
earth to fix some of this behavior you
do some emotional spending and you've
had some immaturity and some weakness
that has led you to that you are not
defined as an emotional spender and
that's what you've got to change the way
you just said that is so empowering i
don't know how the culture got sideways
in this yeah but because we want to be
victims instead of victors
but you know do you realize how like
what you just said is so much more
empowering than oh honey you've you've
got an emotional spending problem
disorder it's not even a disorder but
yeah that's what she wants to say versus
you made some bad choices
struggled with emotional spending to
fill an emotional void yeah yeah well i
mean i'll struggle with chocolate chip
cookies to fill an emotional void too
but i'm not one yeah
my tendency is to i have the same one my
tendency is to emotionally eat so i've
got to set up some you're not a gummy
bear oh god almighty i can get after
some gummy candy but so here's the thing
i have to set up a lot of boundaries in
my life
ask people i ask people in this building
to hold me a candle today well yeah
here's the thing when you go through
something like that that is not an a
fact instead it's a perception right
then what you have to do is you have to
change your mindset about it and so
um i i think there's a whole lot of hope
for her and what her husband is afraid
of and it's coming out as anger is that
she's going to stay in this hole because
she believes she is this whole
and she hasn't gotten to the root of i
lied to my husband yeah yeah well and
and on top of that um
you know i just straight up as an adult
who legally can do stupid things did
some stupid things right call it out
yeah just say i did that
when i went bankrupt you know i went
bankrupt because a bar two's thinking
much money
you know and because i was an idiot i
got a phd in the umb and i signed up for
a bunch of short-term notes and stupid
bankers took my head off well i put my
head on the block that's how they took
it off you don't stick your head on the
block you don't want to get it taken off
so um american express calls my house
now it's a wrong number i mean we don't
deal with these people anymore because
i'm not going to ever be back so you
have to have a moment in time where you
say i'm sick and tired of being sick and
tired never again right
never again that is not who i am i don't
act this way and you start and it's not
some kind of false new age
affirmation or something but you never
again label yourself
as an emotional spender you label
yourself as someone who used to spend
emotionally
i've done that a couple times in my past
i don't do that anymore no james clear
would say label the opposite i'm
somebody who's a steward of my finances
yeah and i'm gonna literally good with
money now that's right and i'm really
good at staying out of debt and building
wealth so what are the practices i'm
going to put in my oh my god that went
bankrupt that's right
and there dave there are times when i
will not go into a gas station because
you know what's in gas stations gummy
bears oh my gosh gummy candies if i
haven't slept if i'm tired if i'm in a
bad mood i won't go in because i know
that when i go in there you can't go in
a bar if you're a drunk that's right
that's right go sit down at the bar
where everybody else is ordering a
double
if you're drunk and go well you know i
used to drink a lot but now i'm putting
myself in a situation here where i'm
going to drink again don't put yourself
in you can't do that if you've got a
history of that and you've got a history
of this and i had a history of
misbehavior with money but and it was
somewhat greed driven somewhat emotional
maturity driven somewhat identity driven
there's a lot of things that drove it
but all those things are things i chose
right and i can just decide to unchoose
them right
and go but and we had a good call the
other day you and i did about a lady
said how do i break my poverty mentality
and it's it's the same thing only i
think we're probably a little bit more
sympathetic for that yeah than i am with
this one uh yeah she grew up with a
model yeah she grew up with a thing and
she's never seen anything else and
and she hasn't labeled herself with that
she said how do i not be that that's
right yeah and that's a much better
question
than than uh you know how do i work how
do i do better in our finances uh you
don't you decide you're better yeah
and then you work on your finances with
your husband and you may need to for a
period of time uh you need to get out
all the credit cards and chop them up
and you may need to have a real clear
weekly discussion with your husband
about where all the money in the house
is cash with you so that he rebuilds
trust over time because you lied to him
that's right
and there's nothing wrong with that i
mean everybody makes mistakes like you
made hannah we're not shaming you for
doing that but for god's sakes don't
label yourself i'm trying to unshame you
i'm trying to give you your power
another one i get all the time is i'm
not good with math
yeah so i can't do money right well by
god people can do all kinds of sixth
grade math and sixth grade math what it
takes to be good with money
this is the ramsey show